Brett Kavanaugh Supreme Court nomination
that remains in suspended animation
tonight thanks as you well know to
allegations that he assaulted a
psychology professor called Christine
Blasi Ford some 36 years ago while both
them are still in high school
despite blanket media coverage the basic
details of that story remained murky for
it has not said when or where it
happened precisely she has said she
didn't tell a soul about it for three
decades there are significant
inconsistencies in her account but we
have never doubted Ford's sincerity and
we've never questioned her motives
unless we learn new facts that give us
reason to we won't do that we give her
every benefit of every doubt but there's
another side to this story as well Brett
Kavanaugh he's also got a family and a
career and a reputation and all have
been gravely damaged by these claims now
Democrats could have helped clear this
up weeks ago if they had asked Cavanaugh
about Ford's story as he sat before them
for days in the US Senate that's what
hearings are for but they didn't do that
instead they hid what they knew in order
to cause maximum political damage now in
the process they overturned his life but
they also overturned Christine's Ford's
life she had asked to remain anonymous
Democrats betrayed her and they dragged
her into the public eye now Ford says
she's had to leave her home because of
threats Democrats in the Senate did that
purely for partisan advantage and you
should keep that in mind the next time
they lecture you about how much they
care about women so what happens next
well 36 hours ago Democrats were adamant
that Ford get a hearing on Capitol Hill
the domination couldn't move forward
until she did they told us it's only
fair now they are saying precisely the
opposite of that
watch Hawaii senator mazie Hirono
explained that having Ford testified
before the Senate would itself
constitute a form of abuse I'm totally
disappointed that all these people who
have come forward to say we should hear
from her and now that she's expecting a
modicum of fairness so she's not
revitalized or now saying well she
doesn't want to testify we should just
go ahead that is additional callousness
from my colleagues that I am totally
appalled by they are trying to set up
and he said she said scenario and bully
her into either testifying on Monday or
not being heard at all these people in
Congress right now and that Senate
Judiciary can
these white men old by the way are not
protecting women they're protecting a
man who is probably guilty did you get
that last part not just men but old
white men the worst kind the kind you
should be punished just for who they are
if nothing else the story has opened a
window into how many on the Left really
think it's a tribal worldview where
people are not regarded as individuals
with distinct personalities and beliefs
and aspirations but instead as faceless
members of ethnic bloc's sorted by genes
it's a world where some people are
inherently good and some are inherently
bad it's a place where how you're born
determines what you're worth that's what
the left now believes they say so all
the time but remember you're the Nazi
here so shut up well you either find
this brand of hard identity politics
disgusting or you don't
Hillary Clinton is drawn to it like a
bear dove doughnuts she came out of
semi-retirement last night to weigh in
at length on cable news here's how she
said the Trump administration ought to
respond to the allegations against Brett
Kavanaugh watch a White House could
answer it very quickly by asking the FBI
to reopen its background check and to
take into account the accusation that's
been made and to gather the evidence
about what can be known but I think the
White House and the Republicans on the
committee are trying to do is you know
basically put her in the dock and try to
rush this through now just pause for a
minute and savor this imagine you're
Hillary Clinton imagine saying something
like that you'd have to believe that the
internet doesn't exist that there was no
record at all of anything you had ever
said in public about claims of sexual
abuse well as it happens we have access
to the Internet here as well as a pretty
long memory Hillary Clinton said an
awful lot about sexual assault
allegations credible allegations
including of rape all of them aimed at
her husband bill for many women over
many years
Hillary sounded a lot different than
like a totally different person of
course she was fighting to keep
political power and that gave her
another perspective watch as Hillary
Clinton dismisses and
littlez the claims of female abuse
survivors we're right in the middle of a
rather vigorous feeding frenzy right now
and people are saying all kinds of
things and putting out rumor and
innuendo it's just a very unfortunate
turn of events that we are using the
criminal justice system to try to
achieve political ends in this country
and I just think that a lot of this is
deliberately designed to sensationalize
charges against my husband because
everything else they've tried has failed
the great story here for anybody willing
to find it and write about it and
explain it is this vast right-wing
conspiracy that has been conspiring
against my husband since the day he
announced for president oh how times
have changed one thing that has not
changed is that torrent of propaganda
from the left whenever their control of
this country is challenged they will say
literally anything
Jim shoot Oh for example a former Obama
appointee now posing as a journalist
over at CNN summed up today's news this
way quote the offer to Christina bazi
Ford is blunt testify in public six days
from now while under death threats or
your allegation will be ignored in the
confirmation of a SCOTUS nominee in
other words says Jim cheeto Republicans
are jeopardizing Ford's life by asking
her to tell her story not only is this
overwrought and dumb it's factually
wrong Republicans want Ford to testify
because they want to get this over with
and vote that's what you do in a
democracy
they've even offered to interview her
privately in California senator Grassley
sent a letter to that effect
just recently Democrats oppose that of
course they'd like to ride this story
into November and beyond
instead the left is calling for an FBI
investigation the FBI wants nothing to
do with any of this as we report on this
show last night so Democrats are now
demanding that Trump order the FBI to
investigate this story but investigate
what exactly where would you start
Ford cannot even state definitively what
year this supposedly happened and by the
way why would the FBI be in charge of
the investigation nobody's even alleged
a federal crime here if you really
wanted justice in this case you would
bring it to the police in Maryland
that's a state with no statute of
limitations on sex crimes
how would that end well ford says
Cavanaugh was a juvenile at the time if
evidence of his guilt emerged would he
be tried as a minor
what his record be sealed afterwards so
it wouldn't overshadow his life
if those sound like absurd questions
that's because this whole thing is
absurd the Democrats don't care about
Christine Ford if they did they would've
outed her in the first place they care
about keeping a Republican off the court
which is fine but if that's the case
then make the case for why Cavanaugh has
ideas are wrong but don't personally
destroy a man simply because he's in the
way that's what they're doing and the
rest of us should stop playing along and
say it out loud